[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and as the saying
goes life is good but it can be better
zack snyder's justice league is finally
here and throughout this breakdown i'm
going to be pointing out some insane
details that i haven't seen in any other
videos
i've also just appeared on prime video
uk's new show the screen test to discuss
the best war movie of all time
with chief film critic of the
independent clarice lockery and joe
kimwin from the cybernets so i'd love it
if you're headed over there
after this anyway our film ends with a
lot of major teasers towards what could
be coming down the line
if warner brothers hashtag restore the
snyder verse
which go on yet do it this includes a
look at the war machine batmobile from
frank miller as the dark knight returns
which is one of the most iconic
incarnations of the classic car
however you might also notice that not
only has batman stop
killing but he's also captured some of
the mutant gang members from that comic
if we zoom in on the clip we can
actually see their infamous red visors
on over their faces
making this for a cool little callback
to the comics that's not the only detail
hidden away at the end either
and when martian manhunter is flying
away from bruce's lake house
the lake itself is purposely shaped to
look like the bat symbol
we can also make out the hall of justice
which is currently being constructed
teased at by bruce this actually appears
as something that's destroyed in the
nightmare timeline
the hall is situated right in front of
the dark side of mega symbol that batman
emerges in front of during bbs
and thus we can gather that it was not
only connected to the lake house
but also the bat cave itself which he
was hiding under during that timeline
now in that scene we saw as the dark
knight travelled to get the rock
to star and black adam this was a trap
and he ended up being captured by the
sons of superman
which led to his death during this
moment superman took his cowl off
and held it in his hands which is what
we see him doing in this clip
likely meaning that this happens after
he murdered bruce i kind of feel like
every time we go into the nightmare
version that it's a slightly altered
timeline
in which bruce refused to lay down his
life and that each incarnation we see
showcases bruce's death at the hands of
supes in each one he's trying to get a
certain object to defeat the character
and this is why they have
inconsistencies across them
joker also discusses how many nightmare
scenarios that the dark knight has
created because he refuses to sacrifice
himself
and we know from behind the scenes info
that snyder was always planning to have
the fate of the world rest on his
shoulders
in justice league two and three you can
also catch killerwog here who is one of
the high ranking members of the green
lanterns
when passing through the rubble we can
also make out the joker's card that mr j
gave to bruce at the end of the film as
a way to cement the truce between the
pair
looks like this truce with bruce was
kept through the majority of the
nightmare timeline
as we can also make it out as something
that stuck to his gun in bbs
now during darkseid's rampage he shoots
omega beams out of his eyes
and these spell out the word end however
if you like to reach
and i don't mean reach around yet this
also looks like a good spell out zs jl
aka zack snyder's justice league other
cool little details in the nightmare
vision are that in the aftermath of dark
side killing lois
you can see the robin suit that dick
grayson had on when the joker murdered
him
typically in the comics it was jason
todd who fell victim to the clown prince
of crime
but snyder changed it to dick to explain
why grayson wasn't in this universe
it was explained why bruce never took on
another robin
and hey i guess snyder he just doesn't
like sidekicks
or dicks now we see the bat cave at
several points throughout the movie
and during one we can also make out the
armored bat suit in the background which
batman wore on bbs
another thing you may notice is that
this shot has been repurposed from man
of steel
in that it came after supes had just
killed zod and in doing so
made it so he just destroyed his last
connection to his old world
luckily he was comforted by lois who
kept him from going off down a darker
path
however with darkseid the villain kills
lois and thus he
is vulnerable once more which explains
why he turned into a tyrant
it's not the only callback to man of
steel either and there is a scene in
which clock pulls off a christ-like pose
above the earth
when he returns to the farm there are
also echoes of his childhood
here we get a shot of the swing and an
image of a kent staring down from a
window
a butterfly too appears at these moments
and this plays a big part in the motif
of superman's journey
gabrielle lebron pointed out on twitter
that typically butterflies represent
rebirth in flight
and at this point superman has returned
from beyond the grave and he's ready to
fly once more
in the film we see that there's a
pregnancy test in lois's draw
and snyder did confirm that she was in
fact bearing a child
which is confirmed by the baby basket
that she carries into the form
at the end of the film in the theatrical
cut this was a different object
and bruce also says congratulations by
the way
cementing that they're gonna be having a
little baby
a little baby and there's also a sign
for suicide prevention which is a very
important message
and is something that the snyder cup
following have raised hundreds of
thousands of dollars for
it has the tagline you are not alone
which is also a saying that popped up in
man of steel
but here it takes on a whole new meaning
this is probably one of the best
placements of a company in a film
i've ever seen i'm so glad that snyder
decided to include it
superman is a character that has a long
rich history in comics
film and tv snyder wanted to reference
this in his updated adaptation
and the scene in which martha arrives in
hugs clock is also extremely similar to
a moment in the christopher reeves movie
this is followed by a shot from inside
the house showcasing how things are like
poetry
because they rhyme now other carryovers
from man of steel are that on the
kryptonian ship
you also see an open pod which snyder
stated would have belonged to supergirl
during man of steel clark also rubbed
the dust off the top of one of the cap
shields
and we can see this continuity detail
carried across in the movie
in fact superman's quote unquote first
flight are shot in extremely similar
ways across both films
during this moment we see superman exit
the craft in his suit
with the doors opening slowly he then
kneels and
using his intrinsic field levitates the
objects around him before taking off
this attention to detail and repetition
is really well put together
and i think in the words of george lucas
it's like poetry
they rhyme i'll start i'll stop doing
that now now it's clear that snyder and
the actors develop little mannerisms for
the characters to have
and when bruce exits the helicopter at
the start of batman v superman
he steps off before it lands this is
something he also does in justice league
showing how much attention to detail
they were paying cyborg also does
similar motions when his parents die
and at both points in the film that this
happens he reaches out with one arm
almost trying to stop it from happening
steppenwolf 2 shows up at the same spot
as dark side did
and similar to the villain he picks up
dirt off the ground before smashing it
to reveal the anti-life equation
it's like po wait i said i wasn't gonna
say now when superman goes back to the
ship
this scene is very similar to when he
first met his father and was given the
grand tour
there's also a kryptonian scout suit
which we saw in man of steel
and the black costume is of course in
reference to the one that kalel wore
upon coming back to life however the
coloration goes far beyond that
and snyder recently told esquire that
this was also chosen
because black is a color that absorbs
sunlight as superman is powered by the
sun
he flew up into the sky to supercharge
himself before flying off to take on
steppenwolf
we can also see at the front of the ship
is a flattened car and this is a
byproduct of the gravitational force
caused by the world engine
now as for steppenwolf the snyder cut
fells in the plot holes of how he found
the location of the mother boxes
in justice league he managed to just
find an island that was so well hidden
not even diana knew how to get back to
it and a secret tower at the bottom of
the ocean
however in zack snyder's version we see
him using a spider-like interrogation
device
that sits over someone's face and pulls
their thoughts out directly from their
brains
in my opinion this is actually the
snyder verse version of star
of the conqueror an alien that would
attach to someone's head and then
control their minds
the villain is rumored to appear in the
upcoming james gunn suicide squad movie
so hopefully we see more of it soon but
also
hashtag restore the staros snyderverse
okay and before we get into the next
part of the video just a quick thank you
to all of you watching this for getting
the channel to the point that i was
asked to be on the new movie vodcast the
screen test on prime video uk's youtube
channel
hosted by that handsome devil jack
howard the show has three guests fighted
out every week to decide
which movie a tv show is the best of the
best in its genre
we talked saving private ryan which was
my choice the hill locker and apocalypse
now
and broke down each movie with their
most memorable scenes
what had the biggest impact and a lot
more it was a really really fun episode
and
you need to go over there right now and
say i won otherwise i'm gonna kick off
yeah i
swear to god yeah i'm gonna kick off
don't make me do it now the episode is
released every wednesday at 5 p.m
and it's on the prime video uk channel
which is linked in the description right
below
if you want to listen to it while you
walk it's also on amazon music
or wherever you get your podcasts at so
i'll see you over there after this
now throughout the film there are some
cool little cameos and when lois goes to
get coffee at the start of the movie
you might notice zack snyder sitting in
the window mark mcclure also appears as
a policeman
at the superman memorial in the
theatrical cut he showed up as a
security guard for the prison
but here it's more linked in with
superman because the actor actually
played jimmy olsen in the original
superman film series
mark plays a character called jerry
which is a reference to jerry siegel
one of the creators of the man of steel
i'm also sure right
and and don't quote me on this i'm sure
the homeless guy that we see
linda reid giving her tips to i'm sure
that's the joss whedon nightmare
timeline version that we see in the
theatrical cut
it's the same dog i'm telling you it's
the same dog anyway
linda reed is also the name of a golden
age character who was a love interest of
green arrow
but snyder has said there's no
connection and this was purely
coincidental
a huge thank you to saini raj for
pointing out that cyborg is resurrected
with object 61982
if we break these numbers down and
assign them dates they equal
june 19 1982 which is the day that
cyborg was first introduced
now shout out to whitfist on twitter for
pointing out that during the flash
introduction scene
we can see a truck pass which has the
name gardner fox on it
this was actually the name of the person
who created the flash and there's also a
sign which says
reduced speed ahead which is an odd to
the speedster that of course lives in
central city
flash states that he's fluent in gorilla
sign language and this is likely setting
up how the character will communicate
with one of his big villains
gorilla grodd should warner bros manage
to go a movie without completely
destroying everything
another great easter egg appears in the
intro when we visit the mascara
and see where the mother box is held on
the roof of it is a star
and this symbol also appears on diana's
tiara we also see hippolytus robe is
similar in design to the armor of
asteria
who appeared with it in wonder woman
1984. now throughout the movie there are
loads of little characters that pop up
including ares and zeus
and also y'all and gur who was a green
latin from the golden age
that protected the space sector that it
exists in
a snyder also played some call backs to
other films in the movie
as not only is the scene in which
superman arrives similar to how the
t-rex did in jurassic park
joe morton's character silas also
references his previous roles
joe played miles dyson in terminator 2
and this revealed that he was a top
scientist at cyberdyne
the company that created skynet however
it goes far beyond
him just creating a machine that can
destroy the world and his death in jl
also mirrors that movie miles killed
himself with a remote control
and through his switch which is similar
to how silas dies
in justice league hashtag spoiler alert
anyway that's the most obscure
references that i could find
i will be doing a big big big breakdown
on the film
that covers it scene by scene just in
the meantime i wanted to get some of the
more niche ones out the way that i
haven't seen mentioned in any of the
breakdowns or videos
i had people sending me stuff like
martian manhunter
he's in the end you might miss him i
didn't miss the lad yeah
i'm just doing the obscure ones yeah and
count yourself bloody lucky i blurred
your name out
otherwise yeah me and the boys would be
bloody coming for you
you do not want to see ryan airy when
you do a mum joke about him
now if you want to see something
included in the big breakdown i was
talking about
and make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize through on the 31st of march
in which we're giving away three copies
of a marvel 4k boxer of your choice
all you have to do to be with a chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now say that to you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the ending of the film
or head over to my amazon prime uk video
which will be linked on screen right now
but out of the way thank you for sitting
through this i've been paul and i'll see
you next time
take care peace